each of these songs represents a scene a
movement in some cases a sonic
revolution that completely altered the
course of popular music they're all also
calling cards almost for those cities
songs totally linked with their cities
identity and might be why you probably
consider them to be music cities now the
magical mythical thing the thing we kind
of all love about stories like these is
that those cities weren't doing anything
in particular to make those moments
happen there's no formula for capturing
lightning in a bottle a formula didn't
give us grunge music or introduced Tupac
to dr. Dre and there's definitely no
blueprint for how to open your record
business in a South Memphis neighborhood
that turns out is home to Booker T Jones
William Bell and Albert King so this is
just something that happens and right
when the stars perfectly aligned great
music just happens and in the meantime
New York and Nashville can churn out the
hits that come through our radios define
our generations and soundtrack our
weddings and our funerals and everything
in between I don't know about you but
the very idea of that is just deadly
boring to me there are musicians all
around you making powerful important
music and thanks to the internet and its
limitless possibilities for creators to
create music and fans to discover that
music those zeitgeist songs don't have
to be handed down to us from some
conference room full of songwriters in a
corporate high-rise but also and more
importantly we can't decide that it's
just something that happens because
music is about so much more than hits
those big iconic moments that change
everything it's more than just
entertainment for so many of us music is
truly a way to navigate life a means of
self-expression sure but it also helps
us find our self-worth
you're out who we are it connects us
with other people as almost nothing else
can across language barriers across
social and cultural and economic divides
music makes us smarter and healthier and
happier music is necessary what if you
lived in a city that believed that that
said we're not waiting for that hit song
to define us we're a music city because
music is necessary by seeing music is
necessary a city can build two things
first an ecosystem to support the
development of professional musicians
and music business and second a
receptive and engaged audience to
sustain them and those are the two
critical elements of a music city a city
whose leaders recognize the importance
of music for our development as
individuals our connection as a
community and our viability as a vibrant
place to live
see smart cities music cities know that
thriving nightlife a creative class
culture is what attracts young talented
people to cities it's what brings that
lightning and know we can't predict the
next egg that will hatch but we can
create a city that acts like an
incubator to do that first we got a note
we've got that means identifying and
quantifying our assets we need to know
them backward and forward from who and
what and where they are to what their
impact is on the economy let's count our
recording studios and our record labels
our historic landmarks and our hardcore
punk clubs
we should count monthly free jazz nights
and weekly folk jams music schools
artist development instrument shops
every lathe and every luthier music
museums open once a whuppin year round
and music festivals open just one
weekend year now ideally through this
process we'll create an actual asset map
dropping a pin for each one allowing us
to see exactly what we've got
we're organic momentum is already
happening because it's not enough to
paint in broad strokes here when it
comes to specific support for music
locally and abroad understanding of a
music brand nationally you've got to
have the receipts next we'll need to
identify our challenges now it's
important to note that for the most part
this won't be just the opposite of step
one we won't gain a whole lot by simply
thinking about what's missing from our
map instead we need to approach this
more holistically there are lots of
music venues on our map awesome but are
they struggling do we have a venue
ladder which just means can an artist
starting out at a coffeehouse open mic
see a clear path for how they'll grow
from that 25 seat room to a hundred seat
room and so on or are we expecting them
to go from a coffeehouse to a Coliseum
maybe our challenges lie in city
infrastructure public transportation
affordable housing maybe like in London
where the number of music venues went
from 400 in 2010 to 100 in 2015 we need
to think about protections against
gentrification the mayor of London in
December of last year actually added
something called the agent of change
principle to the city's comprehensive
plan the name says it all
if a real estate developer wants to
build condos next to an existing music
venue the developer is the agent of
change they have to take the necessary
steps for noise mitigation next and this
is a very big one we need leadership and
we need a strategy now we know there's a
lot of magic in this mix a lot of right
people right place right time and that
will never stop being an important
element of the way music is made the way
some of the best most enduring music is
made but there cannot be a leadership
vacuum in 2018 thriving music cities
don't often happen and don't have to
happen accidentally
we need elected officials who recognize
the power of music and elevate the
voices of creatives and there
to put a strategy in place in music
cities from Berlin to Paris to Bogota
music advisory councils ensure that
musicians have a seat at the table their
volunteer councils and they work
directly with a designated advocate
inside of City Hall or even the chamber
of commerce the strongest strategies
will build music community supports like
this one in word while also exporting
music outward they go hand in hand we
look inward we create that place that
musicians want to live and when we look
outward we build opportunities for them
to advance their career while also
driving attention back to our city and
leveraging music as a talent attraction
tool here's something else that will
help with that we've got to figure out
who we are
now when I say Austin you probably think
live music capital and why because in
1991 leadership in Austin saw something
percolating with an existing asset and
they chose to own it by recognizing that
momentum naming it and claiming it they
inevitably caused more live music venues
to open existing spaces to add live
music to their repertoire and they
created a swell of civic buy-in around
the idea which meant that it wasn't just
a slogan in some tourism pamphlet was
something that locals really started to
believe and take pride in now generally
speaking what Austin created is just an
assets based narrative and we think back
to step one we know that every city will
not tick every box many cities won't
have recording studios like Memphis or a
songwriter and publishing scene like
Nashville and that's not a deal breaker
we simply have to find the momentum
happening in our city what are our
unique assets in comparison to no other
place so if all of that sounds like
something you'd like to happen where you
live here are three things you can do to
move the needle first you can use your
feet your ears and your dollars show up
be that receptive and engaged audience
that is so necessary for a music city to
thrive
a cover charge buy a record discover new
music and please take your friends - you
can use your voice buy into the assets
base narrative talk about and celebrate
what your city has and three you can use
your vote
seek out leadership that doesn't just
pay lip service to your city's music but
recognizes its power and is prepared to
put a strategy in place to elevate it
grow it and build collaboration now
there really is no telling what city
could be defined by a certain scene or a
certain song in the next decade but as
much as we absolutely cannot predict
that what we absolutely can predict is
what happens when we treat music as
necessary and we work to build a music
city and that is a place where I want to
live thank you
[Applause]